the conference is about to start and
we've got 10 minutes spare which is just
about the right time to show the
periodic videos so
it's on screen people are enjoying it so
job done what elements their favorite
caesium of course
so today it's the fifth Ethiopian green
chemistry workshop and we finished the
scientific meetings and now we'll have
an activity where we're going to build
an Ethiopian periodic table so each of
the participants of the students has
been asked to translate one of the
elements into Amharic a literal
translation or their best best
translation possible
it took meant that I have many years
hopefully it'll take us a few hours you
know seven is called 7up because it
originally had lithium in it I see
phosphorus the literal translation is
not a problem but they don't have
Amharic names so there is no American
for it
[Music]
this one's interesting even is a place
with ASA Church so we're trying to make
literal Amharic translations of the
ethiopian translation of the element
names i'm one of the girls has just come
up with a fantastic name for magnesium
element number 12 she called it Lalibela
now Lalibela is a very famous place in
the north of the urban of Ethiopia where
there are a number of churches that are
carved out of the rock these monolithic
churches and there are 12 of them so
she's called magnesium Lani Bela a
fantastic local Ethiopian name
we see with curly pointy teeth we wanted
more papers everyone's finishing and
they need to do more we're gonna need
more elements its aluminium sunshine
them aluminium 13 because there are 13
months in the Ethiopian calendar is
called calendar because it's different
from other countries that we have
searching - including what you call
power me
so what why we are I am writing
aluminium ass
yes words like that oh it's it's a big
event creating the periodic table but
it's really there and by working as a
group that we've managed to translate to
a reasonable degree of accuracy that the
elements of the periodic table there's
some fantastic names like Lalibela for
number 12 because there are 12 churches
and an aluminium 13 there are 13 months
of sunshine so this is fantastic so
we've had really good fun and what my
colleague brainy will be doing would be
to be making a video and he'll be
putting it on YouTube and you'll see
everybody contributing to making the
periodic table and everyone can see it
there all because you tell their friends
and their children and it's something
that you can remember for the day
you